The Joe Rogan experience.
Gilbert Godfrey is a legit comedy legend.
Is he still in New York city during all this crazy? I'm sure he is. Yeah.
Has he caught the COVID yet? I don't think so. How do you live in New York city?
Stacked on top of people and not catch it.
That's crazy, but they also seem to have a really hunkered down and sort of,
sort of, you know, done a good job at closing it in.
I think they got the scared out of them in the beginning,
because they were sort of embarrassed, right.
Because New York was the first one to really get it. Right.
Well, you know, it's a lot of it was those nursing home cases. That's,
that's a horrific story, man.
Again, people don't even talk about this. It's so bizarre. It was like a,
almost like a mini genocide, what they did.
Well, they didn't know any better or they didn't know what to do.
Or what's weird is when like Cuomo goes on.
CNN and talks to his brother, they don't even bring it up.
Creepy. Um, uh, I'm going to tell you,
I'm a proud Italian guy and I can't stand those two guys. I mean, I really,
really truly dislike them. The Cuomo brothers.
And I hate that people like them. Oh, but they're chemistry.
They're good together. It makes me mad. What makes you mad about it?
They just are such faith.
Phony fricking just,
it just exudes fakeness to me.
Well, if you have to be, if you're going to be on CNN,
there's is a certain amount of what you do. That's coordinated and programmed.
It's just how it is. There's just a certain amount of it, you know?
But I, it seems like, uh, Andrew is, uh,
over time is having a hard time deal dealing with, uh,
the questions and. Andrew's a big guy.
Cause Chris is like six, two.
Chris is the one I dislike the most. Yeah. Well, you know, you,
you know about him going out with the Corona virus and all that or not having it
or whatever he did.
Well,
he went to look at property that he was developing and some guy yelled at him.
You're supposed to be quarantined. He's like, you. They got into it.
On the live show. He's in his basement.
Well, that was fake. Yeah. Yeah.
Like I'm finally coming out of the basement for the first time.
But in his defense, that is what they would ask you to do.
They would make you do something like that. If you want to work at CNN,
like if you want to work, forget CNN.
If you want to work on a television show and they know that this is an
opportunity to film you coming out of the basement, they go, come on Chris.
I was like, well, make it like it. Like, he's like,
I've been out of the basement the whole time. There he is ready?
No back down again. Okay. We'll try it again. One more time, Chris.
I'd like you to come up, but this time just a little less enthusiastic.
Kris Krohn returns to basement from his basement. Quarantine play the video.
No, don't what a doofus it's. It's so phony.
He gets up there and his whole family has to play along with it. Like,
Oh, here it is. Finally. It's over.
I finally made it. Please stop. Stop shaming. Don't make me.
It's unbelievable. Don't make me.
It's supposed to be an honest news network.
Well, it's, it's a program. It's a,
it's an entertainment program about the news. That's really what it is.
And it's an opinion program about the news.
It's not like just like the AP. Okay.
Like associated press. You can read stories in the associated press.
They're generally like their tone is very, um,
it's neutral. They're just explaining facts. You know, that's what I,
I try to read stuff. That's just the facts.
And then I'll read opinions on both sides to try to mess my head.
Yeah. It's crazy.
CNN has gone haywire though, man. I mean, they are just,
death is coming to all of us 24, seven a day.
No matter what is happening in the news.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.